hey guys Pete here it's time for this
week's spoiler report from the Game of
Thrones filming not as many photos this
week in fact none like we got out of zoo
maiya but still a lot to talk about as
the name suggests this video will
contain spoilers the kind of spoilers
that can potentially ruin some of the
main characters plots for you if you're
not on board with that you'll want to
stop watching however I do have a
giveaway going on so check out one of my
new non spoiler videos about dragons to
learn about that everyone I'll stick
around to the end of this video to learn
more but then obviously go check out
those videos too with that out of the
way let's jump right in
so filming is wrapped in the locations
that were being used for Dragonstone and
that one beach scene we got out of
King's Landing this location was unique
because the crew wasn't able to keep the
prying eyes of photographers out line
producer Peter welter talked about how
they tried to reach agreements with all
the property owners in the area but
weren't able to do so that said he was
pleased with how the filming went
despite the leaked photos and I think
this means we won't be so lucky at the
other locations as said there are really
no set photos this week but there is
some epic news about the filming of the
season finale before I get into that I
want to mention one other piece of news
that slipped out because it also has big
implications Watchers on the wall are
reporting that their sources say that
the iron bank of Braavos will rear
they're greedy head this season and we
know exactly how Tyco and mistura's
played by Mark Gatiss will make a house
call to King's Landing and more in Queen
Cersei that their debt to the iron bank
is due they say that it will not be a
strange narrative detour or a cameo
either they've learned that Circe's way
of dealing with this debt will have
substantial ramifications in the rest of
the store that's big because the iron
bank our representation of powerful
finance ears in the real world we have
seen them switch sides in the show to
make good on collecting their debts and
in the end you must realize that they
will always get their money in short
they don't care who pays them as long as
they get paid
we know searcy wasn't very interested in
making good on the crown
that before Tommen was dead and it's
hard to dream up a scenario where if she
suddenly decides to do the right thing
now my best guess is she will do
something impulsive with not much
regards to the consequences yeah I know
I'm really going on the limb here but
this will end up compromising her
already weak position let me know in the
comments what you guys think well she
just six omni mountain on him or do you
see a different way out for her
the next bit of news is unprecedented
stressing the word unprecedented because
we really have not seen anything like
this in the show before early this week
the normal cast member photos started
popping up from seville seville is a
place we've seen in a few of my spoiler
videos now and reports indicate that
this is the place they're gonna be using
as the dragon pit in King's Landing in
my video a few weeks back I talked about
a meeting there with Daenerys Brienne
and Davos that by itself is pretty
exciting I'm not sure if this is related
but here's the thing the photos of cast
members kept coming and Jeremy Podesta
posted on his own Instagram account that
he was in Seville working now we know
from confirm reports that Jeremy is
directing the first episode and the
season finale I also talked in my last
boilers video about him filming a beach
scene that involved Theon getting beat
up by his men it isn't conclusive but
considering the lineup in Seville all
things point to them shooting the season
7 finale there by now you're thinking
why why is it the finale and what's so
unprecedented about it well like I said
the cast members kept showing up there
before I list them all off a couple
things we know that the location had to
be closed off from from the public for
two whole weeks just to prepare it Game
of Thrones reportedly employed 400
technical staff because the job was so
big also we know that filming is only
scheduled for a few days so while they
may be filming several unrelated scenes
here we've only got news that one
director is there now for the list of
actors who've been confirmed as being in
Seville pay attention because the list
is long as
today the actors who play these
characters are on location Queen Cersei
Lannister sir Jaime Lannister Qyburn Sir
Gregor could gain serve Bronn of the
Blackwater King euron greyjoy Queen
Daenerys Targaryen
Tyrion Lannister Sir Jorah Mormont miss
Andy Varys Theon Greyjoy King Jon Snow
sir Davos Seaworth Brienne of Tarth
Podrick Payne and Sandor Clegane
let that sit in for a minute
all the living Lannisters both cocaine
brothers Theon and Euron Greyjoy the
king in the north
the mother of dragons and so on in so
forth for perspective the show has 23
starring cast members and 13 of them are
confirmed to be shooting in Seville
Washington they'll all say that three
you know four of these people are
considered guest stars that makes the
number 17 but I'm not sure who is
counted as those four you can see in the
list above that the most notable missing
people are brand re a little finger and
Santa who should all be holding down the
fort in Winterfell right now other
notables missing are Yara which is
ominous since both Euron and Theon are
there and Danny's other new partners
from last season the Queen of thorns and
the sands from Dorne for a show that has
been spreading characters out for the
past six season this is just crazy to
have all these people in the same place
the only other seen that clumps close is
when Robert arrives at Winterfell and
the first episode of the first season
what's gonna happen here this is where
the fun begins because the speculation
possibilities are basically endless one
thing that seems to be backed up with
the only behind the
photos we got is that the Lannister army
will be on hand this isn't really
surprising so not much to dwell on there
but it is cool to see all the Lannister
armor in one place
my thoughts are this is not a surrender
I see Cersei going down in flames before
she ever bends the knee so then what has
brought all these people together in one
place there aren't any real clues other
than who's present so as most of you
know from watching my video on the wall
I think that it will come down something
like that would be an event that would
see these rival factions coming together
despite their differences there is that
supposed plot leaked as well that seems
to be a combination of old fan theories
with the info that's already been known
from the set it's interesting that this
person who is supposed to know what's
going on and what's going to happen has
been right about the things that are out
there already but made no mention of
this meeting of almost every major
character in the show that said it may
add some credence to the shot I talked
about in last week's spoiler video being
related to capturing a white you know to
show them to the other people showing up
with one of this gathering would help
convince the other parties they need to
get involved without the wall coming
down the final thing that could bring
them together is a bit tin foil but it's
also fun to think about in previous
spoiler videos there was news about
Danny's army ambushing the Lannisters at
some point and either Cersei or Jaime
coming in contact with Tyrion what if
that actually hints at one of them being
captured no doubt if there is one way to
parley with Cersei it would be by
presenting her captured brother / lover
not to mention Tyrion knows this is her
Achilles heel better than anyone so tin
foil but completely plausible despite
the lack of any other evidence at first
when I read this I was like oh no this
confirms Yara is killed by Euron but
after thinking about it more not sure
why he would really need to present her
for this if he was holding her captive
it's crazy to think about all these
characters together no matter which way
you look at it if
and Littlefinger were both there too
that's really the only way I could think
the tension could get thicker let me
know in the comments what you think it
all means while you ponder it I will put
up this photo from Instagram of Jon Snow
in his king's gear that comes from the
mountains dawg
or at least an account that for the dog
that is most likely curated by his
daughter
it's from using FaceTime so it's grainy
but you can see what's you know what it
looks like
and check out the little Pomeranian up
there in the corner is there a scenario
where both Tyrion and Cersei walk away
from this with nothing happening between
them what about sander and gregor
clegane
well the Hound still care about the
mountain once he knows that he isn't
really himself anymore what's gonna
happen between Theon and Euron do you
think that this means Yara sleeps with
the fishes
how will Circe react to Queen Daenerys
who clearly fits Maggie the frogs
prophecy as being a younger Queen coming
to take everything away from her and
what will she think of the king in the
north
the one who defeated her Bolton wardens
of the north and who is harboring Sansa
who serves he still holds partly
responsible for Joffrey's death so so
much to take in the hype continues to
grow please like the video if you're
diggin it and be sure to subscribe to
become eligible for the new book
giveaway also follow me on my social
media accounts you can find the links in
the video description or on my channel
page and I'm always on Twitter when I'm
not hanging around YouTube about the
giveaway when I hit 28,000 subscribers I
will give one lucky commenting fan a
copy of the great looking 20th
anniversary edition of Game of Thrones
it's illustrated and it really looks
cool if you go look at the images online
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and comment on any or all of
the videos where I mentioned the
giveaway for more info on how it works
you can check out my Dragonstone video
to see how the winner was selected last
time plus check out all my other spoiler
and non spoiler videos while you're here
there's a lot to check out and a lot
come this week thanks for watching I
will talk to you soon